on tv
on radio and on your smartphone this is
talk tv
[Music]
tonight on piers morgan uncensored with
me jeremy kyle
stabbed for his words as salman rushdie
fights for his life will discuss one of
the fights of his life the defense of
free speech
our proposal which is to prevent those
energy prices going uh increases going
forward
starman chameleon emerges from his
summer in camouflage but is labour's
energy crisis plan of colorado
the england players protesting to the
referee
plus peter schilter one of the greatest
goalies of all time on keeping the dark
secrets of his gambling addiction
[Music]
[Music]
good evening my friends and a big big
welcome to piers morgan uncensored i'm
jeremy carl now stand by inform the
authorities call off the search parties
take down your posters and relax my
friends because sakia stamina has been
located safe and well there he is
finally back from the beach with a
massive plan to tackle your cost of
living crisis he says he wants to freeze
your fuel bills no word yet on whether
he'll stop blowing hot air to facilitate
that but at least he's back on dry land
which is more than can be said of our
prime minister boris johnson who is
again on holiday not another one yes
dear another one the pm's on his second
holiday in a fortnight last week in
slovenia this time in greece but do not
fret because officials insist he's
working from home we wrote this yeah
right next week he's working from rome
but speaking of dry land
the arid arid land of great britain some
great news my friends it's raining
give me that umbrella watch this we
prayed for a downpour and the heavens oh
my it's windy as well the heavens have
opened weeks of baking sunshine have
left the uk as dry as prince andrew's
armpits but now three days of
thunderstorms are set to drench the
nation it's raining cats and dogs out
there i stepped on a poodle in the way
in
goodness me from sizzle to drizzle from
pain to rain we're building back water
drip drip hooray or not big news sadly
the met office says otherwise
demonstrating
don't be too late demonstrating
britain's limitless capacity for
innovation in complaining about the
weather experts tonight say it's the
wrong kind of rain intensive downpours
apparently won't actually solve the
drought crisis this yellow arid land is
so parched it can't absorb the water
meaning we're going to be flooded
instead so we're still doomed and we're
going to be just as miserable but it
does of course beg the big question what
on earth is the right kind of rain
because i must like you think that all
rain is supposed to be wet here's a
really interesting man from the mess
office to raid on our parades
change is on the way next week with some
heavy rain in places but at first it
will come in the form of thundery
downpours
intense thunderstorms are the wrong way
to end the drought the rain will be hit
and miss some places will stay dry and
where the heaviest rain does occur
there's a risk the rain will run
straight off the parched ground and
cause flash flooding
what happy happy news right first
tonight does free speech ever go too far
legendary british author salman rushdie
was stabbed on stage in new york state
last week he's now off a ventilator but
remains in a critical condition the 75
year old has faced years of death
threats over his novel the satanic
verses which some muslims see as
blasphemous comedian dave chappelle was
attacked on stage in may and netflix has
faced repeated calls to drop him over
his jokes on gender and trans issues
really there are attacks on free speech
so literal and so dangerous but
performers face the ever-present threat
of cancer culture on the same day the
rusty was attacked comedian uh jerry
sadowitz had his edinburgh show axed
over complaints of racism and misogyny
and of course britain's own jimmy carr
faced a massive backlash for a joke
about gypsies and the holocaust a joke
he said could have ended his career so
for us tonight there's one big question
is there such a thing as too much free
speech or should we always defend the
right to offend now joining me from new
york i'm joined by conservative author
douglas murray uh to quote piers morgan
douglas has the world gone nuts my
friend
you said at the beginning is there any
limit to free speech and i'm rather
disturbed we're still discussing this
it's
three decades or more since the satanic
versus affair
it was in 1989 that the ayatollah
khomeini did the unpardonable
unforgivable thing of calling for the
murder of a british novelist for the
crime of writing a novel and we had
these debates back then
uh oh where are the limits to free
speech has mr rushdie committed a crime
as well as the ayatollah and a lot more
guff like that i'm rather disturbed that
in all the decades since with all the
people who've been killed for asserting
their right to free speech they're
asserting their right to say what they
think and to and for the rest of us to
hear it but we're still at this
elementary playground level of
discussion i'm sorry to say that but
this is a long
long answered question our societies
have perfectly good uh incitement laws
in place the rest of it i'm sorry no
we're not adapting our own uh
speech codes we're not going to make
ourselves more sensitive to people who
famously burn books that they can't even
read i mean the ayatollah never even
read the satanic verses when he asked
muslims around the world to kill salman
rushdie
an unpardonable thing that has happened
it is extraordinary to me that we're
still having this discussion we had the
same discussion seven years ago when the
cartoonists of charlie hebdo were being
murdered we had the same discussion
in all of these decades and it's muslims
and non-muslims have been attacked and
we in the west still have this pathetic
discussion about oh what are the limits
of free speech really we've got to get
better than that um douglas i agree with
you but it's not just islam is it we'll
talk to abdel al andalusi in a minute
but it's also comedy we talked about
dave chappelle we talked about jimmy
carr there doesn't seem to be a week
that goes by without some comedian
making a joke that
a certain group a certain uh number of
people find distasteful i i obviously
can't be true but well i obviously come
from a different planet because here's
what i would say
we have an on off button if you want to
go and see a comedian you buy a ticket
if you want to watch a television
program you pick that channel if you
want to read salman rushdie's book you
surely have a right are we not getting
to the point where free speech is under
attack in our
world but well it's been under attack
for a long time i don't particularly
care for a lot of the sort of um
bellyaching and complaining on rather
frivolous online stuff that i hear from
a lot of authors and others i think that
people have to toughen up a bit on some
of that uh but this the rushdie affair
has always been in a different class and
there's a reason for that and there's a
reason why so many people today are
willing to make death threats against
authors and others for all sorts of
things including comedians and it's
because they saw that it works it works
when the ayatollah called for the murder
of salman rushdie people on the left and
right of british politics and british
culture made excuses for the fatwa i'm
sure we'll hear some excuses today they
learned our societies learned that if
somebody says i'm offended and then says
and as a result i'm going to kill you
better be damn sure that you're willing
to die for that and unfortunately the
success of the ayatollah's fatwa among
other things is that it showed a load of
other disgruntled people what they could
do if they only had the had the
disgustingness to think that they could
exercise violence uh as an opposition to
the pen and i'm afraid that what
happened as i say is that muslim
extremists across the uk and across the
world showed they could intimidate
people and others undoubtedly have
learned from this but let's remember
britain in 1989 we allowed muslims in
bradford to burn the quran to burn some
of the satanic verses on the streets of
britain we allowed prominent figures
like kat stevens to excuse the murder of
salman rushdie on the television we
allowed iranian officials who had called
for rushdie's murder to live in london
like how stupid are we
interesting douglas thank you for now
new york let's pick up now with
journalist martha gill emma wed from the
free speech union co-founder of the
muslim debate initiative abdullah al
andalusi let's start with you if we can
abdullah um
quite a strong rhetoric from douglas
murray
i'm always aware that
muslim extremists do not in any way
speak for the majority of muslims but to
be fair the iranian government over the
weekend said russia was to blame for
being attacked that is completely and
utterly despicable isn't it
well firstly um
i find it rather
strange that douglas murray who's had a
history of advocating for restrictions
on muslim speakers at universities you
can answer my question
that the iranian government have said
that he took it on himself he was
stabbed in broad daylight i know
but if i may um he he danes to say he's
a champion for free speech so to speak
but yet he his organization argued for
restrictions on uh for platforms for
muslim speakers going to universities he
wanted to ban the burqa in public
buildings and you and a kind of social
ban on it in public
um so for him and argued that muslims
for muslims in europe must be made
harder across the board let's bring this
back in
dug this way i find it a little bit i
would find a little bit strange that he
should um deign to call himself um
brazenly call himself some or at least
imply he's some kind of champion for
free speech
free expression look i probably got to
answer that you'll have noticed and all
of your viewers will notice that this
islamist lunatic in your studio can't
answer the basic question let's try it
again and make it simple for you why
don't you say whether or not you are
completely condemning of any violence
against salman rushdie or anyone else
who is deemed to have said something
heretical why don't we start with the
basics for you
okay firstly i want to answer his
question because he asked me first which
is about the iranian regime well having
not been an iranian citizen nor
participate in any elections to elect
the iranian regime the reign doesn't
really represent 1.8 billion muslims
okay so if you're here representing 1.8
billion muslims it's very simple douglas
has just said it do you do anyone do all
right as your own self having heard what
he said do you accept people saying be
it the iranian government or muslim
extremist and i made the caveat and i
repeat it wasn't extremist that one of
the biggest problems i have is that
people look at the whole thing and they
shouldn't do you
agree with anybody who comes up with the
sentence he was to blame for being
knifed in broad daylight 15 times in his
neck do you the only person to blame for
knifing of salman rushdie is the
the assailant himself not not the
iranian regime who put the fact well on
him in the first place well unless you
can unless you can demonstrate that they
were specifically colluding or they sent
an agent they said he was too lame
he was in communication with the
arraignment and that's that's their
opinion right but i'm only here to talk
about if you're asking me who's to blame
i say the assailant much like douglas
murray said that the christ church
killer the one who massacred the muslims
the only the killer was to blame not
those who radicalized him into viewing
muslims
what you'll find is that if somebody put
a millions of dollars on someone's head
yours for instance or mine and somebody
then attacked us you would think that
the person who put millions of dollars
on our head would bear some
responsibility because you're such a
dishonest weasel you're not even willing
to do that you're not even willing to do
the basic thing of condemning the attack
sticks and stones
you need to demonstrate the person the
person was motivated by the award i'll
tell you what i'd like
this is my program martha gill
journalists what's your opinion on this
situation
well it's it's completely horrific i i
completely agree um
with the other twos with douglas murray
um in that uh if putting a bounty on
someone's head in the first place is an
act of violence uh whether or not that's
followed up by people taking taking on
the challenge and clearly uh somebody
has and they are entirely to blame for
that let's move on to um
i wanted to ask you generally you've
been quite open about free speech when
does free speech cross a line martha
so every society has every functioning
society has to have some limits on free
speech if you agree with any law on hate
speech then you agree on limits uh to
free speech in society um you know if
you say actually
it's fine to say anything you quickly
run up against the paradox which is that
you say it's fine to somebody to go on
tv
and call for the death of somebody else
for an expressing of you so their
freedom of speech is immediately
restricting
the freedom of speech of others so you
do need some limit on free speech in a
free society now of course we can argue
where you draw the line he's going to
say
emma would you say we've gone too far
in restricting free speech i think
absolutely we have i agree with douglas
that i think that short of incitement
those things that are illegal under the
law incitement being things like for
example putting a fatwa out on somebody
that would count as incitement in my
book because it's actively calling for
violence against someone um and in this
case for something that someone has
written doesn't compel people to
if you are through a group or a clan or
whatever you want to say and i'm
treading carefully for obvious reasons
if you feel that you're following uh a
group whatever it is and they're telling
you to do something you've got you're
sitting there saying that that bloke
wasn't i mean that's not my free will
though isn't isn't that the whole basis
of the western system based on people's
freedom do you believe that man would
have gone and stabbed salman rushdie
unless he had been encouraged
incentivized galvanized whatever words
you want from people the iranian
government who say salman rushdie is to
blame i'm putting a fat war on his head
that's wrong i'm simply saying that
unlike knee jerk dog whistle politics we
hear from douglas murray
um
we why don't we wait to the court case
to see what motivate the individual i'm
waiting for the evidence i'm waiting to
like what does he say motivation
fatwa fine i accept do you not think he
might have been i guess he's yeah he
might have been right yes um i'd love to
finish
go so we have in this country a teacher
who is still in hiding the back the
teacher from badly grammar school
because he showed a cartoon of the
prophet muhammad to his class he's still
in hiding with his young family that is
in this country now i think that what we
have done as a result of everything that
happened with salman rushdie in the
intervening 33 years i think that we
have internalized this census this
attitude of censorship so that now if
somebody wanted to write a book like
salman rushdie's book there no publisher
would touch them because they would know
what the implications would be for that
person because we've internalized the
we've internalized sharia law on this
we've internalized in in many ways we've
internalized the censorship of radical
ideological groups
i don't think you can compare a a
illiberal regime such the one in iran to
the one here
that's not what i was doing no no of
course but you can't really compare the
types of restriction on free speech we
have some restrictions laid down in law
they have some they have a huge number
of restrictions enforced by their
government and ruling groups the way
that free speech gets restricted here is
more by process of consensus and debate
like the debate we're having here on
where line should be drawn it's often
done with individuals you can pretty
much say anything you like if you find
the right audience for it i would love
to sit here all night i literally am
being shouted out
we could continue this uh to all of you
abdullah thank you so much indeed uh
douglas murray from new york martha gill
uh and obviously emma webb everybody has
an opinion um
somebody said to me today the attacker
of salman rushdie like millions of
others worldwide almost certainly had
absolutely no knowledge of the satanic
verses a book that came out 33 years ago
so one would have to wonder is he just
an evil person or is he motivated what
are your thoughts it's important at the
end of the day everybody will have their
own opinion don't go anywhere next on
uncensored the big news so kiyostama is
back the opposition leader has risen
from his son lounge who put down his
paperback not the satanic verses and
finally broken his silence on the cost
of living crisis the big question should
our non-existent government who we
haven't seen listen we'll get the
lowdown from my experts it's coming next
we're coming right back in three don't
go anywhere
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back my friends now we've given
sakia stamina a hard time recently for
holidaying in a national crisis but like
a british trade my friends he's arrived
late and lacking power but he does at
least have a plan and in the absence of
anything much from the british
government we thought we'd have a look
at it let's cut it down labor says it
will freeze the current price energy
price cap which is 1971
quid and they believe that could rise to
4 000 pounds by january so they're going
to freeze it at that 1971 quid it'll pay
for that labor says by back dating the
windfall tax on oil and gas companies to
january which will raise eight billion
pounds quite useful they'll also then
cancel the planned 400 quid rebate
before you go
on energy bills that'll say 14 million
which it also reckons will reduce
inflation saving another 7 billion on
government debt now here's the
interesting thing because we have been
moaning at stammer and the opposition to
come up with something good because
we're waiting for the tories to choose a
new leader and the tourists are waiting
for that new leader to tell them what
the hell is going on today the times
reports that 75 percent of grassroots
conservatives black even back at zakir's
plan so here he is the man with the tan
explaining it in his own words have a
look
our proposal which is to prevent those
energy prices going uh increases going
forward will also dampen inflation and
therefore the money that would otherwise
be paid on our debt because inflation is
so high would not have to be paid
joining me now is our financial expert
gemma godfrey and debt expert saleem
shafi from money advice service money
buddies welcome both um we have been
saying for a long time where are you and
when you look at labour's plan
um what do you think because a host of
tories are going that's a good idea well
the big problem with obviously the
increasing energy prices is that it's a
humanitarian crisis it's going to amount
to people spending on average two months
salary to cover
their one month energy bill it's
completely untenable so on the one hand
freezing it you know that makes sense in
terms of trying to lessen the burden but
the big problem is some of the
assumptions they're making that this is
going to reduce inflation and that
doesn't necessarily mean that that's
going to happen and also it's a
short-term solution it's like putting a
plaster on something but ultimately what
it doesn't solve is the fact that 30
energy supplies went bust since the
beginning of 2021 and you know what are
they going to be able to do long term to
make us more energy independent i think
celine welcome to the show i think the
message and i and i absolutely agree
with you gemma but the one thing that we
have been calling out for as a nation is
for somebody to stand up from the
british government and say we're going
to do something and we've talked about
you know short-term measures you know
the green level vat on fuel this might
be a sticking plaster but actually
politically the people of this country
are hearing stamina and the opposition
saying something that they think they
can at least think about and the
government's doing nothing it seems
right absolutely this is something that
relates to people's mindsets at the
moment we're in a national crisis
lives are going to be lost this winter
if we were at war what would be what
would we be saying raise the money so
this is a really strong measure to
actually help people feel safe about
themselves if you feel safe about your
energy costs going into the winter
you're more likely to start thinking
about maybe perhaps spending some money
through the next few months and that'll
actually help keep the economy going
we're getting people into the mentality
of saving and hoarding their money when
you get into that then
where is the investment where do people
then start to look forward we had this
kind of thing in 2008 when the
corporates themselves
barely doubled their cash reserves
simply because they are worried about
the future this is now happening to the
nation unless we can kind of get out of
this mentality of hoarding money now and
and help people feel safe about spending
the money we're going to be in a
situation where the economy suffers even
more i completely agree and and i've
talked politically gemma that that i i
feel like stan has stolen a march which
i didn't think i'd ever say but let's
talk about debt um last week we talked
about the housing market we talked about
rentals and we talked about how
difficult it is for people and and one
of the annoying things for me about
politicians i'm not sure they quite get
it the words are fine but people are
suffering and i think saleem's
absolutely right hey i heard that guy
said to me last week or we should all be
aiming towards getting a mortgage what
would you say to the people watching
this right now who are seriously in debt
forget that they can't pay their energy
bills forget that they will not be able
to heat their homes or feed their kids
they're in debt already it's like
they're sinking do we have a message do
we have constructive help for them
because that for me is what should be
happening now absolutely and i think one
of the biggest problems we have is the
interest that's charged on debt yep
because it's not just the amount that's
owed it gets bigger and bigger because
the interest is a percentage of what is
owed and it can just skyrocket and
actually people can find it very hard to
get out of i think you know look there
are lots of different things that people
can do and i absolutely think they
should be going to advice and centers to
try and get some impartial advice but i
think what's really important is to be
able to speak up and try and ask for
help so for example if there's problems
with energy bills utility providers can
actually provide a holiday
and allow people more time more time to
pay reduce their payments because it's
not in the energy companies interest
either that people just stop paying
either same thing with banks what's
quite quite easy to do is fall into an
unarranged overdraft and again what get
whacked with fees and that makes things
worse but calling them up and trying to
get an arranged overdraft again it's not
a long-term solution but it could stop
them slipping but people are already in
debt prioritizing it focusing on the
higher interest debt not getting swayed
into consolidating it and it may reduce
the interest slightly which is good
short term but if you're paying for
longer again that could increase the
amount as well so i think really going
out and trying to speak up and trying to
get some support for each each
individual's personal circumstance is
going to be very important because it
can seem overwhelming and affect
people's mental health i think that's
the point isn't it saleem that there are
a lot of people watching this will feel
they are in such a a rut that they
cannot see any way out they're working i
always talk about the jams talk about
every week just about managing i have
great sympathy for people on benefit i
don't have any sympathy for rich people
who get that the energy cat what i'm
talking about is those people who are
you know the mother and the father both
work right they've got two kids probably
i'm not painting a picture but they're
paying everything out and they've got
nothing and they're really really
suffering and the message i think gemma
makes a great point about mental health
this is dragging this nation down isn't
it it is well just on the mental health
thing if you have stress for 20 minutes
or more just around 20 minutes you start
to damage brain structures inside
yourself which are really about
connecting with people connecting with
yourself being able to express your
issues and problems so alleviating and
putting this price cap
capping the price cap this next few
months will actually alleviate stress
for so many people in terms of debt we
had to just about managing two years ago
it's just about surviving yeah we're
seeing clients now who haven't eaten for
a number of days that's only going to
get worse can i just stop there because
people say oh you do this every night
carly i do because that that is not just
a sound bite people will not be eating
people i mean we had somebody on from
one of those food banks the other day he
said i had a middle class family in
effect i haven't eaten for four days
it's not just homeless people for god's
sake there are people all over the place
going i cannot afford it i had a friend
a relevant story but just take it for
what it is had a mate today went to buy
his daughter her first second-hand car
the apr had gone from 5.9 to 22.5
everybody is struggling and making money
and financial organizations will take
advantage won't they absolutely i think
what we're talking here is about
essential items this isn't somebody
buying a luxury item and having to cut
back this is people deciding again i get
i get asked this
the big question i've been asked at the
moment is shall i stay at home and then
save on my petrol or should i go to the
office to save on my energy bills i mean
that is what people the decisions people
are making just imagine that what would
you say about debt i liked what you said
about dead advice companies are they in
the past have they been frowned upon you
say they care and they can help you yeah
they are this is a caring sector it's a
non-judgmental sector they're in the
roles they do these roles because they
care about people and one thing about
seeing a debt advice agency like
ourselves and there are many others in
the uk too is that we protect clients
from the behaviors of creditors yeah and
when we speak to creditors they behave
they change their tone with us and helps
keep we're like an invisible force feel
for clients and this can make people
feel much safer about themselves much
more relaxed and again be able to get on
with their life when you are when you
are in debt spiraling out of debt and
out of control and debt and there's
bills coming in you can't see any
clarity to your problem what debt advice
agencies will do is is clear the
minutiae out of your brain and give you
a clear path would you advocate them as
well absolutely i think there's a really
clear distinction here between um debt
advice impartial advice that's there to
help and then uh people that the
companies that are there to say well
we're going to consolidate your loans
they're talking about a product they're
selling a product you're right there are
scams there are certain terms you have
to look for so that's that you should
really pay a lot of attention to but
ultimately free impartial debt advice
that's run by a charity you know that is
there to be able to help somebody once
told me a bank manager years ago told me
that banks make money by lending people
money so your theory about going to a
debt advice agency and you know i'm i'm
wallowing and i don't know what to do
you taking it over they want their money
back but they're also gonna have to be
realistic it's like the utility
companies if everybody can't pay their
bills they won't have a business so
people need to meet in the mail just
both of you um the message to people
watching this who are in debt a positive
message a helpful message what would you
say i would say
i think just as brits we tend to get
very easily embarrassed when we talk
about money but there is absolutely no
shame i mean when it's not just at all
levels of society people are living off
credit cards you know but really
speaking up and trying to find a
solution is going to be incredibly
important before it spirals or to try
and help get yourself out of it there
are people that want to help brilliant
stilling
people shouldn't feel alone you're not
alone in this there's many people in
similar positions to themselves and it's
really about just picking up the phone
speak anonymously a five minute chat
with a debt advisor with a money buddy
can be the difference between sleeping
and not sleeping can be the difference
in heating and not eating and you know
what i think about this cost of living
crisis i think it's going to change
people's behavior we've talked about
mental health we've talked about opening
up people going and seeing a doctor or a
psychologist or talking to somebody in
debt or companies we are going to have
to learn to probably be a little less
british in a little little less stiff
upper lip and open up because the
message is everybody's in the same boat
right gemma godfrey salim thank you so
much indeed for coming on the show
tonight right next on uncensored the
most capped england football player ever
we could use one of those caps on the
prize to butter couldn't we did you like
that england legend peter schultz known
his lifelong struggle with gambling
addiction a subject close to my heart
we're coming back in three
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is talk tv
[Music]
welcome back to uncensored now last week
the gambling group behind brands like
betfair and paddy power announced that
its share price is soaring flutter
entertainment said there is quote no
discernible sign of a consumer slowdown
despite the cost of living crisis so as
the general public looks for ways to
ease the burden on themselves are we
turning to gambling as a quick fix
england legend peter shilton regardless
one of the greatest goalkeepers of all
time kept a dark secret for much of his
life a chronic gambling addiction
england's most cat player peter shilton
had the world in the palm of his hands
the glittering club career spanning
three decades representing some of
britain's biggest sides at the time
winning two european cups a u.a for
super cup and a first division
championship chilton represented england
at three world cups lester about some
than others but shelton was a household
name both home and abroad but behind the
fame and the accolade shilton was living
with a crippling addiction throughout
his playing career he was living a
double life as a gambling addict one
that nearly ruined him not only
financially but mentally and physically
peter shilton joins me now peter
delighted to have you on the show thank
you
um how much have you lost from gambling
i would say it was over 45 years but i
would say it was in into millions really
um
i started i had a real passion for horse
racing that was my thing i didn't really
you know in those days when i started
was no slot machines and that type of
thing um and yeah it started out as a
hobby and just gradually got more and
more i owned horses i loved going up the
gallops i loved going to trainers uh
stables and that type of thing but then
the gambling side just accelerated and
obviously
i didn't realize because money fuels
gambling and when you're earning decent
money not like they own these days but
you know you know that there's plenty of
money coming in and that's
the thing that keeps you going really
somebody once said to me about gambling
and i had a period early on in my life
that you you lie to yourself you lie to
everybody around you you make excuses
you believe that that you know that one
big win is round the corner did you hide
it from your wife steph who by the way
you now credit with with helping you end
this 45-year addiction do you remember
that moment though when you had to admit
to her that so much have been lies and
that you were really in the mind
yeah i mean i'd you know i just i've met
steph and you know we i think we knew
very quickly that uh we were made for
each other you know i was going through
a divorce at the time
and um
to be fair you know we we just literally
sort of
i think steph knew there was something
not right you know because gamblers you
just touching it we're very secretive
you know you you can keep secrets you
can uh
from anybody you know you can lie to
yourself you can like
and she knew there was a there was a
problem she'd been in the nhs
and she started working um on me a
little bit you know in terms of trying
to make me realize you know that what i
was doing wasn't right and um it
eventually paid off um there was a
moment when i'd had a particularly bad
weekend
and i went upstairs and i was phoning an
agent that i'd done a job for and just
basically saying can you pay me a bit
early i'll give you a drink
and i looked round and steph was behind
me and
i just knew in her face that you know
she she'd still caught me really did you
break down uh yeah we did yeah i finally
said look i've got to stop you know i
know i've got to stop and i don't want
to lose you and and that was she always
said look i would never have left you
but she did make a few you know
things where she made me feel as though
she might be leaving and and that was
the big thing and also want we wanted to
get married and she says we can't get
married until we sort out you know the
money side of things and and the
security side she talked to my team
about the shock of seeing a bank
statement showing you lost 18 grand um
in one month and how she revealed on one
occasion she found you in the middle of
a night uh in australia in a in a hotel
having an online bet so there was a lot
of duplicity well i was at home looking
at the there was a lot of duplicity yeah
yeah definitely i mean the thing is
you know once i finished playing
football you know and the online started
it even accelerated even more because
she trusts you now pete oh it was seven
and a half years ago when i finished and
i knew myself you know you
i'd unbelievable amount of effort from
steph you know to make me stop
but i knew myself at the time right why
what was the moment why did you know
after 45 years of gambling and wanting
to make get that rush get that thrill
why did you notice i think i'd had
enough of of losing she used to come in
and say um oh it's the losing racing
post you know and and oh yeah
oh you bet you've lost again today and i
kept thinking to myself well i used to
win everything in football you know in
my career well when you when you look at
that the most decorated goalkeeper ever
really the most extraordinary apart from
that cheating thing um but but when you
look at your career and the adulation
that so many felt do you feel that you
sullied that by the gambling do you feel
no because i didn't have to come out and
you know and and
did it affect your game at all no he
never
i had two careers one was football
nothing ever affected football i mean it
was my love it was a you know a job i
was made to do and i you know i i
when i was away from football you know
then i'd sit and in between matches and
gamble and it just gradually got more
and more and more he's going to talk to
you about that i mean
there's a part of me that thinks that
football should be doing a lot more to
stop a generation of gamblers and
drinkers because you know they train for
a couple of hours in the morning these
kids they're on 200 000 pounds a week
they're gonna get into trouble do clubs
need to do more do you think oh i think
so definitely i mean it's it's rife in
football
now you know it's it's made for in sport
generally you know it's it's when you're
competing and then you have a period of
you know having to recover and what have
you it's it's made for um you know
keeping on high and and and gambling and
and yeah you know it's it's rife
definitely rife now and the thing is
when when you're earning money
people can keep it secret but somebody
said to me and i didn't know this until
earlier nearly half of premier league
teams were sponsored by betting
companies last season in newcastle
united and my team west ham what does
that do if you've got players struggling
with those sorts of addictions that
sends a powerful message doesn't it yeah
definitely i mean the the gambling
companies uh you know i've had carl
blanche really since 2005 with you know
with um
improved profits that they've just been
able to do what they want you know they
send up different advertising things my
big thing is shirt sponsorship and
football and you know around the grounds
because i think football's got a very
unhealthy
association with gambling considering
it's it's a family game and it's it's
the beautiful game and and football
needs to put itself in order but i think
you know generally that um a lot needs
doing the government of delaying the
white paper should have been out in
december your wife's death's working
with the government yeah we're doing it
together i mean the reason i came out
was because i i spoke to a charity
called gambling with lives it was run by
people who lost loved ones mid 20s
through committing suicide from gambling
feeling they couldn't stop that was the
main reason and i felt that if i came
out and i said look you know you can
stop it's not easy but if you do certain
things and um that's what my reason for
coming out and i think obviously steph
is he's got a very caring side and he's
very good at
you know understanding people around a
gambler we're looking at steph now you
say she saved you um
when i when i i mean everybody will say
that there comes a moment in the
gambler's life when you realize and
there was something very personal to you
too that clicked it wasn't it yeah i
think you need a reason to stop you know
and uh you know
steph was definitely my reason um i
think i just got to an age as well where
i've just fed up of um you know sort of
uh
living the life of us because when
you're gambling it's not just money that
you're gambling with it's time you know
you spend all day long
gambling and then losing and it's been a
waste of time um i must move on uh very
briefly i wish i had far more time sky
sports pundit graeme souness uh says he
doesn't uh regret describing football as
a man's game after chelsea's rather
dramatic draw with tottenham yesterday i
think we've got this just have a quick
look
all played the game when you see
simulation people throw themselves to
the ground i'm not seeing that in two
games today it's it's a man's game all
of a sudden again and a referee i
thought had a fabulous game other than
some people points out later but i i i
thoroughly enjoyed both games today that
okay you know if there is such thing as
a purist who watches football might get
away with accepting themselves when the
two managers are getting upset with each
other but
i'm saying it's professional sport
that's what it's all about you want to
it so much sometimes you're you can let
go of your emotions and embarrass
yourself
uh unrepentant later on taught sport
your thoughts on that i know it's a
difficult subject um yeah it is in in a
sense but i think graham was saying
really football used to be a bit more
physical people didn't roll over quite
so much when they got kicked and well
can i jump in and say the lionesses who
won the european championships when they
get kicked up they just got straight
back up again
exactly and um was he being misogynistic
that's what he's i don't think so i
think he was just saying that you know
football was a bit more of a man's game
the men's football in the past but
they're you know the lionesses have done
fantastic they're they're
you know in football that's that's their
uh place you know they've won the euros
i mean they're amazing and they show
more than the men's team and one they
were nothing the two are separate but
we're all england and and the fans
showed that the the the celebration for
the for the la for the ladies for the
girls was just as much as uh for the men
peter shelton uh you've been a hero mind
for a long time i'm gonna ask one final
question very quick one would ask the
best player you ever played against
uh he was a cheat uh
maradona oh you got it thank you peter
shelton for viewers who need advice on
any of the issues raised just then
helpline information is available at
talk dot tv forward slash helpline so
we're coming back with jesus journo's uh
talk legend mike graham and political
correspondent ava santina and next on
uncensored don't go anywhere
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back my friends time for jesus
journos i'm joined by talk tv's legend
mike graham and political correspondent
ava santina they've become
you are a duo well
we are officially now because it's the
second time you've had this on it is yes
and last time well it's quite successful
wasn't it well it was actually your host
pipe thing's gone viral
i'm gonna start with you football is a
man's game said graham soonest he seems
to have rode back a little bit tonight
probably sky sports of uh um but he
wasn't big he wasn't meaning it like
that he was just saying it was a matter
of two yeah two teams of men were
playing football do you not agree he was
being wealthily ignorant
that's a bit harsh i think he was
describing the game he wasn't describing
women's football versus men's football
he simply saw a game which we all saw
which we all got very excited about it's
been like a bit of a punch-up you don't
want to see the women's coaches fighting
each other but you do want to see the
men's coaches pushing and shoving each
other a bit it's great fun but the point
was he was describing the behavior the
abhorrent behavior of those two managers
and he was suggesting that male violence
is exciting and enjoyable and de facto
is more exciting and enjoyable than the
women's football and that is just that
that is a comment so outdated and just
shows his intended language but how is
he so needed still in football how is he
not allowed to enjoy men's football if
that's what he likes why can't he enjoy
it more than women's football if that's
his opinion but why do you have to talk
about football as if it's two different
sports the male and the female game like
it's one sport and two sides of it he's
like totally segregating both sides when
the lionesses won the women's euros it
was called the women's euros and
everyone was talking about how great
women's football was and it was but we
can't say men's football is also great
but it was brilliant because women were
not allowed to play football for so long
i mean women
for for one
schools one for one in schools at 11 i
wasn't allowed to play football any
longer and hopefully the women you know
that title i am very outside left i'm
uh my name's james welcome to piers
morgan uncensored with david graham
brilliant james that went really well
afghanistan the taliban are subjecting
women there's all sorts of stuff on this
isn't there i think i think it's our
greatest shame actually at the fallout
from afghanistan i think it's absolutely
despicable what this government has done
in terms of getting people back here
there are people over there right now
who work with the british army as
translators as communicators and they're
still stuck there and they are dying
there was a man that i met in calais
just a couple of months ago i met him on
the side he'd come over on a boat
desperately trying to get to england on
the way over here his wife was shot by
the taliban and that is that's the
history that we've left there we have to
agree on that the the
withdrawal disgusting and we i'm not
going to get involved in an argument
with anybody on this but the americans
left left us with very little choice the
americans don't forget left the taliban
billions and billions of quids worth of
equipment you know high high-ranking
military equipment which they've now got
and they can do anything they like with
oh this is this is
watch pretty patel today extraordinary
watch this
we should stand tall in terms of our
collective effort
by bringing over 21 000 people and also
creating a new life for them in the
united kingdom
and that speaks volumes to the great
work the tremendous partnerships that we
have across government the ways of
working at a time of crisis
i have to say uh
ava and i might not agree on most things
shameful and she will not be the home
secretary in four weeks time now the
anniversary of the taliban they're
terrible terrible
still actually doing some work because
i've seen her since july you know she's
not even doing any work because when
she's talking about these people we've
brought 21 000 over half of those people
are in hotels at an immense cost to the
taxpayer and an immense cost to those
people's mental health it's disgraceful
boris johnson today described as a fat
punch ava cena says there's enough to
criticize that lump of lard for without
water
there's enough to criticize him for
without discussing his weight oh my god
i think my eyes never fell off my head
boris johnson's done a fine job though
don't you think look i mean you know you
i think the biggest criticism here is
that he's on holiday the last thing that
he did before he went on holiday was he
had a meeting with the big energy
company and he decided that what was
happening was really shocking and awful
for the british people but he couldn't
do anything about it so he was going to
go off to greece that doesn't make any
sense let's bring in quickly so
kirsten's broken cover tonight back
beneath stone island top and they've
come up with this plan which 75 percent
of tory voters say and for me very
quickly david it's about um sorry
they're actually talking because we're
hearing nothing from the government
because that's the only plan they've
seen they haven't seen a plan for the
tourists so they see a plan from kirsten
uh already though uh it's been
criticized as it will cost twice as much
as he says it because it actually costs
60 billion quid and as far as boris is
concerned we'll let him stay on holiday
what's the point of him even having a
job anymore he's out of a job he's not
the prime minister he can't do anything
let him have a long holiday stay in
greece until october but did he did he
actually i mean i i'm not sticking up
for him because i'm scared of you a
little bit um did he want to stay on or
did he
my thing about starmar is at least and
i'm not saying it'll work but at least
he's there on a television screen saying
to these people suffering in the country
do you know what there is something well
he didn't mean but he's in majorca last
week wasn't he yeah he wasn't also you
know back to his peers policy that's not
really a whole policy it's about a tenth
of a policy very very quickly pets i
know you're you're into pets um loads
and let millions of people had pets
during lockdown because they didn't get
on with their partners i suppose it's a
sweeping generalization and now because
of the cost of living they're giving all
these pets away there's pets everywhere
apparently they're letting snakes and
lizards just out in the street so i mean
when the the torrents of rain water it's
raining cats and dogs cats and dogs
but there's also going to be snakes you
know there's going to be lizards there's
going to be terrapins all floating down
the street because people have just
thrown them out into the streets
disgraceful just floating telephones
there's david graham yeah how exciting
let me spice up the cost of living
crisis are you a pet fan i i mean i'm
not a massive pet fan i live in london
so i'm not allowed to have one in my
flat am i so you're not allowed to no no
you're not allowed to if you're
everything most landlords don't let you
have you got any pets no i've got a dog
have you been ziggy yeah
my favorites my favorites jose's
journals are the legendary mary graham
what did you really call me james mike
back tomorrow morning 10 a.m on talk tv
uh also ava santina will you come back
next week i love you i would love to are
you happy to come back i'd love to
fantastic thank you both very much
indeed uh bear in mind we started this
by telling you it's absolutely hacking
it down it is hacking it down all across
the united kingdom way but don't worry
it's just gonna roll off the earth and
not work that is it from me whatever
you're up to tonight pierce made me
absolutely promised to say this keep it
uncensored have a great night i'll see
you tomorrow at eight o'clock you ready
for this
[Music]
join me ian collins every day on talk tv
there is nothing we hate more than
hypocrisy discussing the big issues why
was it so hard to establish the deputy
leader was at a meeting with her
colleagues the callers alan in grimsby
tracy in burton on trent dave thank you
very much picking apart
the beast this simply does not wash look
who's back under the spotlight
this is talk tv news
good evening i'm nadira tudor zakir
stama says labour's energy plan is the
real answer to the cost of living crisis
and the opposite of what the
government's offering the labour leader
said he would act now to stop energy
bills rising saving people one thousand
pounds this winter paid for by extending
the windfall tax heathrow airport has
extended the cap on passenger numbers
until after the half-term holidays the
existing limit of one hundred thousand
travelers departing per day has been
extended until october the 29th due to
staff shortages and the uk has become
the first country to approve a covid
vaccine that specifically targets the
omicron variant the new moderna jab is
expected to be used during this year's
booster campaign all over 50s and people
in high-risk groups will be offered
another jab from next month that's all
for now we'll have more after the talk
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign